[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna do the question of the day I
am from Karachi Pakistan I'm nervous but
got them from blast everyone looking for
my face I want to be a little bit
challenged so to be ready in September
for school you need to analyze
literature so the first thing I want you
to do and Allah gave everybody their
dictionaries in your language I want you
to translate these words if this program
didn't exist there would be at least
seven children that I teach right now
that we have no idea what's going on
it's going to be the action word
[Music]
Zain and his siblings are all of my
students the situation in Pakistan
became very dangerous and it was at a
point where their mom was concerned that
one day they could very well go to
school and not come home I try to let
those children open up through their
writing but they've been a little
hesitant to talk too much they're so
nervous so very quiet and people will
then assume well the student is too shy
[Music]
[Music]
community and many better ideas
so to say for any context
Pakistan me versa totally machi Holly
can marry Pacheco charter school in a
hinge re taking a haladki Jessie [ __ ]
coding in Pakistan our knife floor is
really fearful every day there's bomb
blasting people's and you know hundreds
of hundreds of people are killed
[Music]
my sister's sleep here and the moms
sleep there that's my bed actually to
look like tiny but not too much but it's
all right knee open it's gonna get
bigger
my big brother sleep here and my second
brother sleep here maybe that's no we're
just like sleeping much yeah it's so
relaxing
look at this wall tentacle do you man
then me receptive to both elkerton 32t
Barton Helios Kuno stratagem Montek you
yet okay kandi mama a friend indeed
madam
[Music]
the man poachers approach vocally and
hingle certain correlations a safety
measure of 13 cm per sector has
approached a baby boy he died
okay
I'm fine
because I look like I love trees I love
grass I'm like I love nature scope
attack you have them warning album here
knocking and see it's not have education
kidding me cause she was a rule for you
okay thank you what do you imagine in
your future in this country where do you
think you'll they look like in living in
like a big house not big like regular I
don't want to look big house ignite like
a Burgess my sister and my mom and you
all be together yes for happen that's
all like the full video my favorite
sounds like ridiculous bilities I like a
dance I like his life I like his my can
ants on the one from the my sister
although she like friended me I can tell
I'm a Sikh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so images that we saw or things we heard
singing what did I check out filled a
reg - yes what does this word mean
student look at you guys I got some real
New Yorkers in this room okay don't run
since i made it here i can make it
anywhere
what is he saying you can make your
dreams come from
ah you can success here you can success
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway that way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to government
[Music]
Luna train colors they're not here
anymore this is where the building was
and it's to honor those who lost their
lives on that day rain John
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Morland is before I eat breakfast before
school
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the talent show is coming up soon
how are you feeling about it I've been
nervous
I'm gonna dance a bunch of doofus for a
bunch of people and I like Harvest
I'm prepared to do it I'm gonna do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and cited to come here friends teachers
are wonderful
Jane has really blossomed I know that so
many of these students have gone through
some very traumatic experiences in their
lives
he's definitely opened up a lot with
them sharing with them his Zane wisdom
[Music]
[Applause]
to carry you through September
[Music]
whenever you feel nervous or afraid
remember the community if you have felt
here and know that each and every one of
us here are rooting for you we have your
best
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to like said go out to prove my
innocence I was learning English that's
on top of you if other than I can talk
good thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]